greece started like scuttling ships and
just kicking them off they built a wall
they they would uh they were yeah they
also built a wall yeah it's very good
they built the wall came out yeah that's
a funny thing too i remember when uh
when i went to uh sweden then i went to
europe for the refugee crisis
donald trump was like we're gonna build
the wall it's going to be the greatest
wall and people kept saying walls won't
work because people fly over and then
i'm like a three meter chain link fence
reduced immigration into a camera merged
country
uh by like 90
and the reason was the families couldn't
go over like the father probably could
but the mom and the kids couldn't climb
the fence so they'd go around well and
so just literally just a chain-link
fence well walls walls also work when
you when you man them yeah i mean they
don't they if if somebody can throw a
ladder up and put it over and then
everybody can climb over yes but if
you've got you know
a moat with alligators well i mean
you've got hadrian's wall i mean it it
this is a system that worked for a long
time you've got the great wall of china
their
walls do work but they require staffing
yeah and you have to you know you have
to say sorry no
stop everybody no
but look look at the look at the border
we've got with canada we have like 3 000
mile unprotected border so yes if people
want to go and go into canada canada
let's you know pre pre-covered canada
let anybody in now if canada is also a
insane asylum uh that that just
restricts every right you could possibly
ever think you had
so pretty soon i guess we're gonna start
getting refugees from canada in the
united states so we'll have to worry
about that border too so this is uh uh
yeah i didn't see this story check it
out from reuters august 21st greece
completes border wall extension to deter
potential afghan migrants and uh there
it is i mean that's a hefty wall looks
like it's got barbed wire on it
notice it looks better built than ours
yeah what's up with that
it's a boundary with turkey it is
bollard fencing it's it's very very
similar but it does look better like
ours look rusty what was up with that
you know
they built it with rust
well also then you have to remember you
wonder if when the greeks build that
wall if they're also thinking about the
fact that they offer that they tend to
maybe go to war with the turks yeah like
okay
is this is this just one more sort of
you know discouragement to the turks
roaming in and and attacking them
because they're still divide
cyprus
you know it's like the the global order
is is is collapsing it's not just the
united states it's all of this
international trade you know uh uh when
we were hearing china was turning back
ships from american companies because
they wanted to keep the equipment with
the ppe and stuff like that just the
whole system is like what's that the
center cannot hold thing i mean you know
we we've we've all four of us lived in
unprecedented times and we're still
we're still benefiting from the post-war
boom from from world war ii world war ii
blew up
the
manufacturing and
you know the cities of pretty much
almost every civilized nation
and coming out of it you know it states
we didn't do it yeah so we built we
built tons of factories and soldiers
came back they we had this manufacturing
base and
we're very difficult to invade at least
as a military because where we're
located and we're armed to the teeth
yeah and so we still we're sort of
basking in that
but times change technology when when
the internet got invented
fortress america went away
because suddenly
russia china and iran anybody else who
wanted to involve themselves in america
could do so every single day they could
do it on the internet and social media
made it worse
it's not let's talk about you know
russia i'm talking about rt i'm talking
about you know chinese chinese media
chinese have
i
facebook won't allow itself to be based
in china oh we're not going to go in
china there they got the great chinese
great firewall of china but meanwhile
chinese
so chinese media companies have 751
million followers on facebook oh yeah
751 million followers
and pushing out pro china propaganda i
don't see facebook kicking them off they
don't see them restricted because they
don't dare mess with china and not to
mention in fact of course the money
they're getting from the ad placement on
those 751 million you know
users yeah i was looking at facebook
followers man these politicians will
have like 600 000 followers 300 000
followers people i've never really even
heard of or just starting to hear of
it could be that could be a good thing
that they're becoming famous but they're
not really that special of people like i
don't they don't strike me as like
exceptionally talented or intelligent
maybe maybe intelligent maybe but they
just they put them so they ran for that
position they won the popularity contest
and now they're
super like 27 year old people have
hundreds of thousands of followers that
will never leave like for the rest of
their life those people know who they
are
and
this it's disturbing it's disturbing
that that a politician might make a life
out of it
that that is not tenable well so we we
live in a narcissistic culture
we've exported it now to the whole world
to sell out your your ethics to get
reelected is like it brought us to where
we're at right now i think well it's
it's not just re-elected it's get famous
i mean yeah it's what was swole well you
know okay if you're if you're
uh
not especially famous congressman
and some hot young girl wants to
use the air quotes again euphemistically
date you
and
you know
alarm bells should go off in your head
if she's super hot and no chinese uh
somehow that sort of thing it should
should occur you see it all the time the
the the frumpy weird kid you know
and he's he's you know uh
just trying to be cool and fit in and
then all of a sudden this attractive
woman and he falls right for it
you know oldest turns out oldest yeah
oldest story in the book turns out she's
a chinese spy the whole time yeah you
know horatio sans was going through that
his statement was like when i was a kid
i was super unpopular and girls never
liked me and now he's super famous and
he's got all these like 17 year olds
coming up to him and crawling all over
them at bars so he's he's he was a
creepy weirdo weirdo when he was young
and he's an even creepier weirdo when
he's older love you love you horatio no
i'm just kidding i don't know anything
about that guy yeah and i don't know if
he was the one that said that i think
crystalia had said that that like when i
was a kid i had no and so yeah and now
he's older and he's like telling people
high school girls are talking for the
first time but telling people you're a
creepy weirdo when you were young
doesn't excuse you no it's disgusting
but now you understand why they go why
they're crazy like that
why would a famous ordinary people don't
have the opportunities
to
be take advantage or be taken advantage
of the way famous people do and look at
look at athletes
athletes you know the the second
they're identified in peewee sports you
know you're you're oh my god you can
throw the ball oh my god you could run
fast you know you can hit the ball their
lives change
everybody tells them they're great
high school grade schools high schools
college bend over backwards the stars
of our pro sports or even the secondary
or tertiary players in our pro sports
were people who were stars every step
along the way in their lives ravens
right now have a backup quarterback who
actually beat lamar jackson the starting
quarterback when they're in high school
together and and you know and so
now he's a backup quarterback in the nfl
maybe he's the second year the second
quarterback
and
he's always been a star
when that happens you get
know well you'll have women throw
themselves at you or men depending on
you know who you are uh financial
opportunities everybody thinks
everything you say and do is perfect
this is what happens to politicians
politicians get used to yes people
nobody one of the worst problems of dc
is nobody will tell you you know
everybody tell the boss hey boss that's
a really stupid idea
and so it becomes a culture i every time
i hire people i have to sit down and try
to explain to them yes you're allowed to
tell me i'm wrong matter of fact you're
encouraged to do it because sometimes
i'm an idiot that's a good point because
we hire them but then they hire a bunch
of yes men to surround them as they do
their job like their staff
these politicians or their politicians
because yes men surround them and tell
them to run
you know you know what it is uh i was
reading that uh celeb celebrities tend
to be narcissists because narcissists
tend to be the people who insert
themselves
and so when when you know when it's no
surprise the people who are on tv all
the time are the people who demanded to
be on tv because they think they're
better than you
you get a bunch of narcissists and
sociopaths same thing is true of
politicians there's the people who are
like i must run because only i can save
the people it's like you're a nut job
well but i mean that's how do you find
real leadership i mean that's that's all
people in washington i former girlfriend
might tell me one time i was like you
don't have a big ego i said you're just
grading on a curve
you know it's just dc man you know
you're working on capitol hill everybody
in dc's got a huge ego just by
comparison yeah if we could find a way
to use ego for an energy source
dc would would power the universe yeah
the piezoelectricity
measuring the vibration of the brain
waves and creating electrostatic charge
brain waves in dc i think you definitely
would we would be able to power a
flashlight
i mean that's being generous
an led flashlight how about that did you
work like in this in the dc machine i
i've worked in prior to working for
media critics i was in media i spent i
worked a couple daily papers i worked
for chronicle higher education
congressional quarterly uh i've always
worked in media or
in some form or now criticizing me do
you think this is something we've come
up with is that they say politics is
downstream from culture i think culture
is downstream from technology do you see
any any possibility that this system
could be solved politically
well the problem is
political will comes from people which
is back to culture
and you know that's so i mean it's all
it's all synergistic i mean there's no
you can't just take one piece out
donald trump was a great example of how
a combination of technology
and culture people people just wanting
change i know there's a lot of bernie
sanders people voting for donald trump
uh
people were frustrated with the powers
that be
you think people were frustrated the
powers of b where they voted for donald
trump you get three and a half more
years of what's been going on the last
seven months
and they'll be willing to vote for the
you know the ice cream salesman down the
street let's let's let's say
establishment politics we will call
substance x
and substance x has been pouring out of
all of our faucets
and our vents and our tvs it's the block
yeah it's just
sludge and then what happens is trump
comes along and he's like i'm gonna fix
it all it'll go away i'm the best no
more substance acts and people are like
i will take whatever i can get
but what happens is
he plugs it up it starts backing up in
the pipes and now biden is like ultra
concentrated substance acts it's like
it's like it builds up and then trump
holds it back for a few years and then
boom it comes out and you get everything
that people hated about establishment
politics going back for decades biden is
and and with a lot along along with the
media like a hyper concentrated version
of it well it's not just by it's
particularly yes along with the media i
mean
whether how much biden is doing to self
it's certainly the establishment that's
running dc right now is
you know the fact that the woke politics
the work you know stuff in school
critical race theory which is racism
all of this stuff is so overwhelming now
that it it's intended
to overwhelm you it's intended to make
you lose hope it's intended to make you
give up and just accept it we're living
through a cultural revolution
so yes culture so so
all that stuff is still downstream from
from culture but the difference is
culture is now hyper-powered with
technology that it's never seen before
china is doing a good job of mastering
it or at least riding the
riding the fenris wolf you know and not
having it eat them well that's that's
probably my dorkiest reference for the
evening
i think a lot about um deep fakes
because we're coming up on neural net
and deep fakes and like when we see a
deep fake video of a guy getting his
head cut off by a deep fake isis guy and
a deep fake american and we think it's
real and it might be a real fake
person's face on
and then the country goes to war because
of some deep faked false flags running
man
the map that the map where they mapped
the guy and they kill they they kill
arnold schwarzenegger and they just you
know they they map somebody they map
somebody's arnold's face on somebody
else that's with deep fakes and you know
who's most scared of it
politicians
they're afraid for the late hit where it
shows politician x
or substance x within a porno
yeah
uh someone tried making like that i
remember there's a viral video of like
the p tape and they're like it said it
was clearly staged and fed with an
awkward camera angle but it's not even
necessarily deep fakes it's when you
know how they do the the um
what is it called when they make the uh
oh is it that is a deep fake i guess
when they just make a fake person it's
not a real person the face doesn't exist
it's like oh yeah yeah yeah so it's not
like they'll take ian's face and put it
on your body it's like they literally
will artificially generate a face that
is of no person
yeah we got that sites that now create
just build your own avenues do you guys
remember when they made uh the joe rogan
simulator where you could type in words
and it and then it was joe rogan saying
them oh no and it was near perfect yeah
and they they ended up taking it down i
guess you know like it's a little i
don't know if joe came out against it
but like they can do they took
guys who made it it was too creepy or
something
they were making videos of joe saying
crazy stuff to prove a point and it's
like
that's messed up dude yeah right so they
can
somebody posted a video just this week
where it was from canada and it was a
woman saying that isis are brothers
and
i raised question because it it didn't
lip sync out and i still don't know i'm
i haven't seen it that were where it
becomes
proof that it was phony so maybe it's
legit but it didn't it didn't look if
you watched the video
very clearly she's enunciating every
syllable correctly and she gets to
brothers and there's like a little blip
and then it doesn't look right and i'm
thinking is this phony so i mean i i
even tweeted people and i saw several
people raising the question
why haven't we seen more of this like
why haven't we seen you know aoc or
trump or biden or harris oh it is coming
yeah yeah he's right it's coming oh yeah
i mean
imagine what iran or russia could do
putting out a video of of biden and it's
just like deep faked in audio and it's
biden saying something and and they
wouldn't make it crazy like him saying
something like rachel slaughter would be
him saying something like yeah well what
was i supposed to do about these marines
anyway you know what we got more or less
literally saying ephem
yeah just you know from from a little oh
here's a here's a tape because
but the deep state so you can't just do
that because it's it's two people will
be like effort like there's no way biden
would say that his son died of cancer
and served but you know i mean i think a
lot of politicians would say that people
yeah people people would believe it but
i think if we saw a psyop it wouldn't be
that direct it would be something like
yeah well we're sad to lose them but we
got more
well remember that
we're living in the psyop and i don't
mean like some sort of phony artificial
thing the the whole goal
of
foreign governments is to put us against
each other yeah and we're we're living
that every day and i mean the the us
them thing we live the stem thing and
i'm probably you know a good part of
that uh you know
fighting that but
if you look every single major issue now
that's fought on twitter
you run into the bot armies
and the bot armies
make it look
like
oh there's a lot of support for this
thing that well they're their cares
they're not necessarily bots they're
sock puppets yeah sock puppet yeah but
phony accounts or small small accounts
and
that's why you don't read replies don't
read comments
yeah that's why i mean i look for real
people it's one it's one guy like when
you read your comments yeah and you have
like 10 comments whether like you're
ugly you're fat you're a loser it's one
guy it's god speaking to you through
whatever what's funny is when you you
know you delete the one and another one
just picks up right right where the one
left off like of course it's the same
person they think you don't you know or
when they accidentally use their socks
without realizing it yeah i forgot to
switch their accounts yeah this is oh
another zero follower june 2021 account
but nevertheless politicians and
business people don't understand this
yep flat out don't so when tennessee
went to
constitutional carry for guns god bless
them
the i saw some people responding to the
governor saying oh thank you very much
this is great we want next thing the
parade of the accounts and you could
tell some people who are on there didn't
get what was happening
and that's
truly unsophisticated i mean that's
that's you know garbage
entry-level you know
political maneuvering
the democrats have a couple
bot armies or or soccer count armies
russia has at least one or two china has
won
iran doesn't shockingly and they don't
understand you can block people uh
so they're very unsophisticated but
we've now discovered the taliban is so
sophisticated that even the media are
speculating that they've hired a pr firm
so so i mean this is this is affects our
politics
every single day and it's designed from
foreign governments and even people in
our country to pitt us against one
another thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to see the full show come back
to this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time